et si nous avons depuis deux ans renouer
avec la victoire où nous avons gagné
chacune des élections n'en déplaise à
nos adversaires rien ne nous a échappé
nous avons gagné les municipales
souvenez-vous de ce qui a été dit sur
les municipales on nous annonçait des
listes la république en marche partout
et puis après j'ai bien peur de
continuer avec les départementales et
les régionales et on a vu les résultats
auxquels nous sommes arrivés là aussi on
a amplifié nos résultats pourquoi on
gagne dans toutes les collectivités
territoriales c'est parce que on a la
capacité de présenter un projet qui
répond aux attentes de nos concitoyens
sinon gagnerait mort et donc pour cela
il fallait prendre ce temps ce temps de
congé à plat toutes les préoccupations
de nos compatriotes
la droite a retrouvé son adn elle est
populaire est allé solidaire comment
comme on les aime vraie équipe de france
serait prête à gouverner prête à diriger
notre pays
[Musique]